[Musik]
ich gratuliere den piloten und der
besatzungen auch den technikern sehr
sehr herzlich zu 25.000 flugstunden mit
dem black hawk ich sage herzlich danke
auch für das was sie leisten nämlich zum
einen immer dann für schutz und hilfe zu
sorgen wenn das die bevölkerung am
dringendsten braucht ob das bei
katastrophen ist aber auch natürlich
dann wenn das militär gefordert ist da
für schutz und hilfe zu sorgen dann wenn
das andere nicht mehr können
ja ich wünsche dem piloten besatzungen
den technikern alles alles gute und
herzliche gratulation zu 25.000
flugstunden mit dem black hawk ich
wünsche euch in zukunft alles gute
vor allen dingen aber auch dass sie
weiterhin auch für schutz und hilfe
versorgen wenn andere es nicht mehr
können und für unsere bevölkerung da
sind knapp und land
[Musik]